dans moins de trois semaines tout doit
être prêt cette classe de cm2 va être
réorganisée avant le retour des élèves
ou là c'est pas très pratique parce que
elles sont toutes regroupées
mais l'idée vraiment c'est de pouvoir
arriver à aligner et qu'on est bien une
distance d'un mètre entre chaque table
et chaque enfant ici d'habitude ils sont
26 c'est trop le ministre de l'éducation
nationale l'a affirmé aucune classe
n'aura plus de 15 élèves quelle seconde
salle qui est là derrière qui est une
salle informatique
aujourd'hui mais qu'on risque de
réaménager pour pouvoir avoir notre
espace et les gestes barrière à mettre
en place pour les élèves
donc voilà donc cette salle asra on va
retirer le matériel pour pouvoir
reprendre les tables des enfants pour
pouvoir les dispatcher ici en dehors des
salles de classe dans les couloirs à la
cantine sera-t-il possible de respecter
la distanciation social c'est le pré où
les enfants jouent habituellement là
nous avons les enfants des personnels
soignants que nous accueillons pendant
la période de vacances ici avant de
rentrer en classe les enfants se range
serré
à l'intérieur de ces marquages au sol la
question c
le maître de sécurité de distance dans
des petits rectangles comme ça voilà
après ça va être
et concrètement eh bien on va sans doute
prendre si on n'est pas tout les classes
de reprise on prendra deux carrés de
rectangle pour eux une place sur le
terrain toutes ces questions ne sont pas
encore réglés
les syndicats eux craignent que le temps
avant la reprise ne soit pas suffisant
pour s'organise on peut être inquiet
parce qu'on a des dates mais on n'a
aucune information concrète alors qu'il
aurait peut-être été mieux d'avoir des
informations concrètes et puis prendre
le temps de mettre les choses en place
et ensuite peut-être fixé des dates les
grands principes sont déjà fixés par le
gouvernement
les détails comme le port ou non du
masque les tests doivent être précisées
avant le 11 mai